hi Owen hi Martin
many of my cloud Run apps are for
company internal users only and I wish
there was an easier way to set that up
and how do you handle that today
well my users must VPN to the virtual
private Cloud first and then they can
log in again to the applications and
there's no central place to manage
fine-grained access ah there is a better
way with identity aware proxy by using a
zero trust approach there's no need for
a VPN it also gives you centralized
Access Control across all of your
applications
[Music]
you are a product manager for cloud run
focusing on networking and security
right yes and as a product manager I
hear from customers who want to simplify
authentication for company internal
Cloud run applications
and that's where identity where proxy
comes in that's right identity aware
proxy or IAP for short is a product in
Google Cloud that you can put in front
of other applications it only lets in
users that are on its approved list
sounds good and that means security
admins can control access to apps in one
centralized place and also they don't
need to maintain a VPN anymore
and app developers can focus more on
business logic as IAP handles
Authentication
their code simply needs to check a
header and each incoming request this
means fewer lines of code and a lower
chance of Errors due to bugs or
oversights
right I've used iip to manage access to
my web apps on app engine
yes and we recently launched Cloud run
integration to General availability so
now IAP can control access to your Cloud
run applications as well as app engine
compute engine and kubernetes engine
nice can you show us how it works sure
here is the centralized control panel
where a security admin can manage access
provided by IEP
you can see all the applications in this
project here
this is an Erp system that runs on a
kubernetes cluster
this is a cloud run service that runs my
financials
and this is an internet front end that
runs on a virtual machine
and this is a public website that's
hosted on app engine
and the public website is open to the
public
yes it is I turned off IEP for it
all other applications are locked down
my internet website is open to everyone
which is a group I created that includes
everyone with an email in my domain
but the financial system should perhaps
only go up into the finance team yes
exactly if I click the application
go to the info panel
we see that only the finance team has
access
right and when I try to hit your finance
application I get this login prompt and
you gave me an account in your domain
before Martin nachow1x.com so I'll try
to log in with that account ah an access
is denied great
now let's say that you need temporary
access for a few weeks I can grab your
access directly from the info panel
so click on ADD principle
and enter your account
and Grant you the IAP secured web app
user role
so you can grant access to groups or to
individual users that's right
all right let's give the permissions a
minute to propagate
and I'll go to your finance application
again
ah and now I have access
oh uh it shows my account name there how
does the app know
great question
What's Happening Here is that IAP adds
some headers to the HTTP requests
this is the most important one let's
have a closer look
I temporarily updated my application to
print out the value of that header to
the logs just for our demo today for
security reasons I wouldn't do this in
production
so let me open the logs and find one of
those log statements
here's one
I will copy the value
the header name contains JWT is it a
Json web token yes that's right
if I decode it at JWT dot IO
we see that contains the email and user
ID
so your cloudron service has code that
extracts the user ID and email from each
incoming request
yes and here it is this is the source
code that ensures that Google signed the
JWT
so you know it was Google who sent the
request and not somebody else yes
exactly and to be doubly safe the
validation also checks that the request
is for this Cloud run service
this audience parameter identifies a
load balancer back in which in this case
is my cloud run service
and where did you find that audience
string
here it's here in IAP under the dots
menu
very good looks like a useful code
snippet I will include a link to it from
the video description
okay I also want centralized access
control for my applications so I have a
project here with the cloud run service
that is a corporate directory and it
should only be visible to people with
accounts in my domain but right now it's
public so I've already set up a load
balancer with a custom domain
nice show me what you've done so it was
pretty easy to create a load balancer
and add the custom domain to my cloud
run service I just clicked my cloud to
run service
I click the Integrations tab
I picked the custom domain integration
and filled out and submitted the form so
it took a while and now that it's all
done it looks like this
and then I updated the settings at my
DNS hosting service with this IP address
here
and my domain name now leads to my cloud
run service like so
and I can also access the service
through the Run dot app URL that cloud
run created like this
looks good
so this is your current setup and as you
showed there are two paths to your Cloud
run service and neither of them is
authenticated
and I want to force users to go via iip
where I can set 2s access and who
doesn't right
right that is where you want to be and
Anonymous internet user will no longer
be able to reach your Cloud run service
directly
users will have to go through your
custom domain and your load balancer and
they will have to authenticate with IAP
before accessing your service
okay it looks like I need to change a
few different things
yes here is your to-do list first
configure IAP
then number two Grant your users access
to IEP
then number three allow only IAP to
invoke your Cloud run service
after that number four
deny Anonymous users from invoking your
service by requiring Authentication
and finally number five
deny external access to the run.app URL
for your service so the only entry
points will be through the external load
balancer using your custom domain name
okay let's do the first item which is to
configure IAP
all right I'll go to security and then
identity aware proxy
I'll enable identity aware proxy
will give it time to turn on
now I'll go to IAP
looks like I need to configure a consent
screen right this is the oauth consent
screen that will be displayed to your
users on the login screen
click the button to configure it
you will only authenticate internal
users so you will not need to submit
your application for review
now fill in the required fields and you
can always come back later and fill in
the rest
okay I'm filling out the required fields
I click save and continue
I don't believe I need additional oauth
Scopes I don't want to access users
spreadsheets calendars or anything like
that I just want to give internal users
access to this cloudron service
sounds good
for cloud run service name there
on IAP for it
okay I will check the checkbox and click
turn on
looks like it's done
great let's just give it a few moments
for all the changes to propagate on the
back end
then open an incognito window and go to
your domain
all right doing so now
there's the login page very good now
let's go to step number two which is
granting some users access to your
corporate directory app
go back to IAP
and check the check box for your service
right I click add principle like you did
before then I enter my admin account
I'll enter user in my domain Alice
then I give myself and Alice the role
IAP secured web app user
done
great and you can also access to groups
that's easier if you have many users
I use Google as my identity provider so
I create the groups at admin.google.com
also look here I created an everyone
group it includes all the users and the
organization
the docs describe how to set that up now
you're done with to do item number two
in item number three you will grant
access to IEP so that it can invoke your
Cloud run service
the documentation page for using IAP
with cloudrun shows the service account
that you should Grant access to
right I see the account name here I'll
copy it
looks like I need the project number
I'll go to the project overview page to
get that
and then I put that in the account name
I copy the account name so I can give it
access to invoke my cloud run service
then I go to Cloud run and pick my
service
then I click add principle
I paste in the IEP account I have my
copy buffer
and then I give it Cloud run invoker
role
done
now it's time for item number four
deny Anonymous users from invoking your
service by requiring authentication
that's under the security tab
okay I click the security tab for my
cloud run service
and I change it to require
Authentication
and there it's done so will this change
display that login screen for my users
not quite
IAP will display the login screen
this option require authentication means
that only authenticated requests from
other services can trigger the cloud run
service
in our case users will authenticate the
IEP and IAP will authenticate to Cloud
run
and now you've done four out of five to
do items Martin
I wish all my to-do lists were that easy
me too
and your last to-do is number five deny
external access to the run.app URL you
do that from the networking tab on your
Cloud run service
okay I click my cloud run service here I
click the networking tab
and here I set it to internal access and
I allow traffic from the load balancer
done
great now open an incognito browser
window and see if everything works all
right here we go first I'll make sure
that the run.app URL for my cloud run
service has been blocked I'll enter it
here
very good that URL does not lead to the
cloud run service anymore
then I'll go to my custom URL which
should work
there's a login page good
I'll enter my credentials for admin at
my domain
and I'm in it worked congrats you have
completed all of your to-do items and
your IAP setup is complete only the
users you grant access to in IAP will be
able to access your company internal web
app all right shelwin this looks great
uh but what if an organization keeps its
user list in active directory can they
still use IAP yes
if your users are an active directory
and they're using Google Cloud you may
want to use Google Cloud directory sync
to synchronize your Google users and
groups to match the information in your
active directory or ldap server that way
you can use IAP and other identity aware
products in Google Cloud
nice so let's recap a show when what are
the takeaways sure our top takeaway is
that you can use IAP as a central place
to secure all of your Google Cloud
applications hosted on cloud run app
engine compute engine and kubernetes
engine
and what's next for anyone who wants to
try out IP in their project
set it up today this basic version of
IEP is free all you have to do is pay
for the load balancer
if you want to upgrade your Security
even more check out beyondcorp
Enterprise Beyond Corp Enterprise is
Google's zero trust solution that
provides full context aware access
including user and device context and
has integrated threat and data
protection to protect your users from
unsafe activity
thank you for joining me today thanks
for having me Martin
and thank you everyone for watching if
you have questions for Shawano me please
add them in the comments below also let
me know if there are any other
serverless topics you'd like to see in
future episodes I read every single
comment until next time
[Music]